how did we get this far
human beings have an immeasurable desire
to discover to invent
to build
our future depends on us further these
ideas
a responsibility
that rests on the shoulders of
generations to come
but with every new discovery
there is risk
the sacrifice
consequences
be ready for what's coming what is
coming the answers hey youtubers it's
Charlie so this is gonna be a breakdown
to the teaser trailer so a lot of things
different about the film from the
original films or the even the comic
book origin story so I'll try to explain
as we go along generally think of it is
like a version of Chronicle if it were
done like David Cronenberg's the fly
which actually it sounds pretty exciting
the easy into this is that this is the
Brian Michael Bendis Mark Boal our
origin story from Ultimates so just read
ultimate Fantastic Four you should be
good to go if you're gonna borrow from
comic book people Millar and Bendis very
safe bet in this version of the origin
story the characters start out as
teenagers and Reed Richards develops a
form of teleportation as a child he gets
found by a benefactor who inducts them
into a program which becomes like the
proto Baxter building it gets into
endzone stuff so if you're not familiar
with the endzone just read the ultimate
Fantastic Four just read the first run
in that comic their first big villain
was Mole Man but it's basically like our
first step into multiverse so Fantastic
Four is getting to multiverse
so Fantastic Four is getting to
multiverse before the Marvel Universe
before the MCU is getting to multiverse
so we have to give him a high five for
that so let's just start with the big
Easter Egg that Simon Kinberg was
teasing he's the screenwriter he's a big
man on campus with the x-men films he
works on the x-men films a lot and he
also works on Lucasfilm on the Star Wars
films he's a really cool writer he said
there was gonna be a big Easter egg in
the trailer turns out it's in this sooo
storm scene when she's looking at all
the monitors if you look at the IP
address here it actually points to
Marvel's wiki page for the nation of
Latveria so it looks like we will see
some lab area in the movie what they're
calling the movie is a contemporary
reimagining and everyone also wants to
know if this is going to be connected to
the x-men films unofficially it is
officially it stands on its own
I think they're slowly getting to the
place where they can do x-men Fantastic
Four crossovers so going back to the
beginning now if you're not familiar
with josh trank he's mostly known for
doing chronicle which is actually a
pretty fun movie he also just signed on
to direct one of the Star Wars spin-off
movies so he's something of a rising
star so if Lucasfilm thought
was good enough to do Star Wars then I
think it bodes well for this film this
is just a skyline shot of New York City
which is probably buried underneath snow
right now Jung Reed Richards getting
himself into some scientific trouble the
basis of their powers isn't going to be
a cosmic radiation cloud
it's actually going to be a
teleportation experiment so here's
another one of the slight modifications
so the basis of their experiment is
funded by the military
instead of being scientific the US
military is looking for a teleportation
technology here's our first big shot of
miles teller as mr. fantastic if you
haven't seen him in whiplash you need to
see that movie he totally killed it
casting him is like a big 180 from
previous iterations of the character and
I'm actually really happy with this
change mr. fantastic in the comics the
fury de Miz is very cold he's very cold
character very hard to read it doesn't
always play well on screen because he
kind of comes off as a dick he's
obviously a very wide-eyed scientist
very young in this like this is a very
young version of the characters but I'm
interested to see what kind of pathos he
brings to the role like I said just
watch whiplash he has this crazy
intensity in the movie so I'm expecting
something like that in his performance
kate mara is Sue Storm this is actually
where we're getting our first big Easter
egg this IP address down here that I
mentioned this is Jamie Bell as Ben
Grimm aka the thing I'd say of all the
roles he's probably gonna have the most
fun usually it's the villains that have
the most fun but being Ben Grimm you get
to just be absolutely crazy smashy
smashy here's Michael B Jordan as Johnny
Storm and a lot of people were wondering
you know what the relationship between
John and Sue Storm was going to be
they'll still be brother and sister and
and Michael B Jordan is an amazing actor
so is as weird as it might seem that
they're changing the characters so much
I think it's gonna be pretty interesting
I'm more worried about the ability of
the actors than them doing an exact
carbon copy of the comic this is dr.
Franklin storm this is obviously Johnny
storms father so the characters go
through the classic transformation
sequence this is gonna be probably one
of the most fun things in the movie
watching characters get their powers
probably one of the best things about
superhero movies here's our first shot
of the thing there was some
behind-the-scenes stuff that leaked
earlier but I actually think that these
finished effects look pretty amazing so
here's our first shot of a Johnny Storm
as a Human Torch if anybody has been
watching the flash this season this
actually kind of reminds me of the
particle accelerator explosion
except metahumans
are just gonna be popping up everywhere
you have to remember Marvel is the one
doing the Inhumans not Fox although it
does kind of remind you of a Terrigen
bomb
this is a shot of Toby Kebbell he is
playing the Victor Von Doom character
although they're slightly changing the
character his name is Victor DOMA Chev
he's gonna be like a computer hacker
there's not a whole lot of information
about his character beyond that so I'm
gonna wait to talk about him until we
get some more official information so
here's a better shot of Human Torch and
Invisible Woman and mr. fantastic
getting ready to use his powers
obviously they're gonna hold off on
those I'd save all the fantastic forged
powers
Reed Richards powers are the weirdest so
I totally understand why they're gonna
wait to show those off like setting
yourself on fire it looks pretty badass
but just like stretching yourself a lot
is just it is kind of weird that's why a
lot of times I think when you see him in
the more recent comics like the New
Avengers comics he's busy doing crazy
Illuminati stuff not like stretching
himself around all over the place if
there's any crazy alien that I would
like to see them do any any crazy
invading force it would be the scrolls
if they did she are I think that would
show up in an x-men film not Fantastic
Four but I think scrolls would totally
work in Fantastic Four that's that's
really where the rights flow from but
let me know do you guys want to see them
try to do Shiar with the x-men films and
scrolls with the Fantastic Four films at
some point all in all the trailer makes
me very hopeful for the film so so we'll
see it's coming in August so we will get
at least three or four more trailers
before then so we'll see some more
footage once we get to the summer like
Comic Con they'll price start promoting
the hell out of the film so I'm
expecting them to do something pretty
big at Comic Con so once we start
getting some more footage and some more
information about the film I'm gonna be
doing more bonus videos for Fantastic
Four in the comics and what's gonna be
different about this film so be sure to
subscribe to get all that stuff so don't
forget new episode of the flash tonight
pipe Piper's coming on and agents of
shield there's actually a reddit AMA
going on for agents of shield so I'll
post a link in the description right now
while you guys wait for that you can
click here to learn all about gorilla
grodd's origin story in the comics he'll
be coming on the flash this season and
you can click here to catch up with
what's going on in Marvel phase 3 thank
you so much for watching so that's all
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you